so are we or are we not paying upwards
of 450 000 to each family separated at
the border peter ducey tried to find out
from the president united states
yesterday
said that there was nothing to this
essentially
did he get any clarification at the
white house today peter
did you we did we did neil and to answer
your question are we or are we not
paying these illegal immigrants who are
separated from family members under the
last administration are we giving them
cash
not yet is what i just heard
the administration paying up to 450 000
to illegal immigrants who are separated
from family members garbage he says it's
not going to happen
but the aclu says that it is so who is
right if it saves taxpayer dollars and
puts the disastrous history of the
previous administration's use of zero
tolerance and family separation behind
us the president is perfectly
comfortable with the department of
justice settling with the individuals
and families who are currently in
litigation with the us government
so today the president is perfectly
comfortable writing checks to these
illegal immigrants who are separated
from family members under the last
administration that is completely
different than what he told me about
this time yesterday
there were reports that were surfacing
that your administration is planning to
pay
illegal immigrants who are separated
from their families at the border up to
450 000 each possibly a million dollars
per family
do you think that that might incentivize
more people to come over illegally if
you guys keep sending that garbage out
yeah
but it's not true so this is a garbage
report yeah
apparently it's not a garbage report the
only issue with it is the number the 450
000 number is apparently a little high
that's what karine jean-pierre told us
the doj has communicated to the
plaintiffs uh to the attorneys
representing these illegal immigrants
neil
all right thank you very much peter
ducey on that reaction right now from
congressman michael mccaul of texas he
sits on the foreign affairs committee
congressman what do you think
well yeah the president calls it garbage
aclu says it's true
then they backtrack on their story
saying well you know we're negotiating
my sources at the department of justice
tell me that they are negotiating with
the aclu
and the plaintiffs in this lawsuit and i
think you know after what happened last
tuesday a resounding message against the
biden administration's policies
particularly when it comes to this wide
open border situation we have and if we
you know to the deterrent factor you
know i'm from texas and the idea that
we're going to tell illegals hey come on
in illegally break our laws and by the
way we could give you up to a million
dollars per family what kind of message
of deterrence does that really have and
i think that's why they're crawfishing
and they're not really explaining the
story um and they probably want it to go
away uh but this is one of many neil
that i think is a disaster for this
administration
well congress i'm wondering too
regardless of it's 450 000. or 350 250
000. obviously there's a plan up for
payment for family separate i wonder if
it would extend to the same thing that
happened in this administration and the
precedent it sets
it's it's a terrible precedent and in
fact uh neil we know that there are
negotiations going on right now
with speaker pelosi and the democrats on
the reconciliation bill to actually
provide
appropriations to pay these uh
settlements that the justice department
i think is is trying to negotiate right
now you know with these plaintiffs so
regardless of what you thought about
separation of family
i think it's a principle you can't break
our laws and then win the lottery and
the message of deterrence is pretty much
gone
it already has been gone for a long time
when this he rescinded remain in mexico
but then to to telegraph you know to
people in central latin america that you
can come in and get 450 000
illegally a million dollars and this is
what really angers the american people
this is why you saw the result you saw
last tuesday they're tired of these kind
of stories they're tired of what
happened in afghanistan now we have a
state-sponsored terror state and a wide
open border which in my judgment is
former chairman of homeland as a really
prescription for
danger
you know you you mentioned that they're
trying to put this in i assume you were
talking about the social spending and
climate package the democrats are
are
moving quickly to
get together and mark up and vote on i
guess but that this feature is going to
be tucked into that to pay
those who've been separated at the
border do you know that for sure
i know those discussions are underway uh
you know they don't have the votes the
democrats particularly after tuesday are
in complete disarray you know we're i
just got off the floor plus she's trying
to count the votes i don't think she has
them right now
but it's it's things like this that
when people hear this that they're going
to give illegals who broke the law money
but also there's also talks about a
massive amnesty program i don't know if
that's going to be in the final bill we
vote on or not but we do know that's
being considered that 10 million people
could be granted amnesty in this country
that's kind of policy i think that's
really backfiring on the democrats and
is going to give us a majority
in 2022.
congressman you did touch on afghanistan
and i know you and your committee been
looking into this um and now
uh reports that there are thousands
of u.s residents still
still stuck over there can you explain
what you discovered
it's a it to me this was the most
dishonorable disgraceful thing i've seen
in my professional career to
unconditionally surrender to the taliban
and then the state department we have
the deputy secretary of state testify
yesterday they he admitted
as much that they didn't have a plan
they didn't have a strategy to get the
american citizens out of there you know
neil i've got you know these these
private operations are going on uh with
active duty and veterans and private
funding have given me more information
than i've gotten from the state
department
and it's very sad you see pictures of
mothers and their little girls holding
up their blue passports but not able to
leave the airport in afghanistan and the
state department is doing absolutely
nothing
to help them they're left behind and
they're left behind enemy uh territory
with a vein a very dangerous element the
taliban not to mention
these special forces that worked with
our guys and the interpreters that we
left behind that are gonna have a very
bad fate in terms of uh executions um
you know this story's gonna get worse
before it gets ever gets better
and it sends us a it projects weakness
neil
not strength so if you're russia china
iran now you're china looking at taiwan
you're russia looking at uh ukraine
and he's projecting weakness you're
gonna think about whether that's yeah
you know whether they want to move in
and be aggressive so real quickly on
that
real quickly on that congressman um the
administration has now said even through
private means and other means those
people are getting out didn't refer to
the thousands that you cited but that
they're they are going to get out and
efforts are still underway do you
believe that
i met with these organizations this
morning uh finally because of you know
they are meeting to to
coordinate with them but it's these
private organizations that save
thousands not state
they evacuated along with the rest of
the evacuation state is not there
these private organizations are they're
really enclosing the unsung heroes and
the patriots
out of this colossal
failure of an evacuation from
afghanistan
congressman thank you very much keep
posted on this uh michael mccall of
texas foreign affairs committee looking
at twin issues off the border and
certainly what continues to unfold in
afghanistan hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else